foreign
[Music]
we're gonna end with something nice
before we uh go out and stop Asian eight
it's no more murders New Mexico okay
this girl is um I believe she's uh in
her 20s
one day she wakes up just finds out her
vision's going oh that's scary she's
just going blind you know when like
something or whatever detaches like
slowly yeah so she's losing her vision
and then
um a year later after that first initial
like feeling she's now legally blind so
as a blind person she ends up going to
college for psychology meets a really
nice guy who like kind of takes care of
her like uh suggests a bunch of like
helpful things like uh he helps her
start a GoFundMe to like get this
treatment for her eyes and stuff why am
I scared right now and then um and then
he he even finds a surgeon who can do
the procedure that's really needed
anymore scared get her her vision back
so at the end of falling in love and
stuff she's still Blind by the way and
then she's still blind wait did she
become blind or she's she's legally
blind legally blind but when she met the
person she was blind yeah okay she was
blind all the way up like the whole
thing with the dude she's blind falls in
love blind that doesn't know what he
looks like loves the guy she knows what
the dick feels like in her hand
true and a [ __ ] and a mouth he's like
he's right I can't see but oh hey man
hey hey oh no this is gonna be one of
those like the guy was like her brother
or some [ __ ] huh oh [ __ ] what if she but
he would have known some of the [ __ ]
he's like nearsighted so he can't what
if she gets vision and she goes oh [ __ ]
this dude and then she bounces that
would also be sad is that true that's
not ruin the story guys so what happened
is her brother
please be the brother oh this guy's ugly
brother that's cool so sad don't dump
the guy she like she ends up getting her
vision 100 back after the procedure
that's crazy what procedure is this 2020
Vision uh they were just able to
reattach the thing that was coming out
oh really it's not a 100 thing it's kind
of like you know she's probably like oh
this Fool's ugly
she's about to bounce on him she sees
the dude that she fell for for the first
time I told you guys love is not
it's a sick Excel sheet my dude he's
actually pretty hot
he was a good looking dude she's got
great teeth and and then she was like
they got married her actual thing was
wow I can't believe how good looking
this dude and he's a great looking guy
so they get married and everything's
happily ever afterwards he was hollering
because in his mind he's like she kind
of thought hey
yeah I see some potential here I would
have been like what a creep crying on a
blind girl what
I I'm kind of with Joe on that I would
be have you guys uh you guys ever have
you ever
[Laughter]
oh boy I'm sure that would have come up
in one of our stories a long time ago I
um I remember
so so I was I met a girl this was like
in high school and we used to do those
like aim chat things right oh okay yeah
yeah and they got to see to use those
things and then like we you know back in
the day you send each other pictures
right she was a pretty ABG with the
bleached hair nice oh that's a freaking
Gem of its time right and then
um come to find out she told me she was
dead oh oh dope so I was like I mean not
like oh that's what she's typing yeah so
I was like how that yeah dude
that's hot
he's a liar
most deaths also deaf give me what kind
of death
judgmental like I'm just like can we
talk on the phone because she said she
couldn't prove it she couldn't hear
so she's not fully [ __ ] deaf like she
uses a hearing aid she can read lips
she was like nah like I can't talk on
the phone that's a medical term sounds
like a diagnosis but when she speaks to
people she could read lips right and
then she can say some words but then she
has the deaf voice which is
[Laughter]
that's the my poor deaf accent but I
don't I'm you know yeah we're not gonna
dive down you sound like a Vietnamese
Uncle no it's not it's not the truth
that's dope she got the [ __ ] Tom
Cruise though where she could be like
you know Mission Impossible where he's
like
the thing is
so I had a mutual friend that knew her
and I was just like oh [ __ ] because you
know the Asian world was small back then
and then so he was telling me yeah like
she's cool man but like in person you
can't communicate like you got to know
sign language all this [ __ ] like it's
hard to get like okay it's hard that's
why she's online like chatting with
everybody and then I forgot what ended
up happening but I was like I couldn't
further the relationship either like we
couldn't meet up I couldn't talk on the
phone or whatever whatever and then
she'd be like I guess like it was just
difficult to like build a bond off of
just like just chatting but like never
like getting to the next stages so then
I don't know but then I was like I was
cool with it like for me I was like
willing to go forward but maybe she's
been denied a lot or I don't know but
but then again I was like 17. so you
just [ __ ] her in Balance huh oh you're
not even mean boy
Naughty Boy
I got made fun of once we're dating a
girl that had a cleft palate really oh
that's [ __ ] up you know what that is
yeah that's [ __ ] up I was in high
school oh that's [ __ ] up that's [ __ ]
up it's because of the the deficiency in
iron or some [ __ ] right now
but then like people were like does it
feel weird when you kiss your head high
schoolers are the worst man yeah don't
do but she was she it was and is like
gorgeous like she's [ __ ] and she I
thought you're gonna say she had she had
a really good head game so what the [ __ ]
oh my gosh
she got really good head game but for
some reason the top left of my dick
never gets okay here
okay we just lost our attack Club
palette
is that what you no that's what he was
gonna say she paid you on this one
that's that's what Joe was gonna say
dude
when we make fun of people it's kind
of
we
nice in yeah don't [ __ ] hide from
that [ __ ] yeah
she ended up getting it fixed and like
you can't even tell yeah like do the
surgeries to get those things fixed
knockout bait though still is still his
face the things that that people are
like oh man that's this I'm like that's
it I'm like what what are you talking
about the things that people get I don't
know like it's like I don't know man
it's just character
that's all it is we all got [ __ ] up
[ __ ] about us in different ways exactly
that's why I'm like I'm deformed brother
that's why I think it's funny because
it's like I have I have flaws too
okay to just make fun of everything
sorry were you here
nasty boy
dog she looks like a nice lady yeah very
sweet hat but then again making it too
real guys back that is high school [ __ ]
also in in a high school I became
friends with a a deaf B girl
yeah I should dance to the music yeah
was she offbeat well because for deaf
people like if you're playing massive
bass they just make a feeling yeah so
she really enjoyed breaking because they
would always like play the biggest like
boom and it was really easy for her to
like you would never know like if she's
you know dancing that she's she's not
offbeat whatsoever you know how there's
like love stories and [ __ ] where it's
like
oh if a deaf person loves me I know they
really love me for who I am and not how
I look right I'd be blind let me yeah
I'm thinking yeah I was like someone was
lying to you along the way bro so so if
if they were blind I was [ __ ] talk
about death talk so if they're blind
right
and then and then I'd be like
but do they even think I'm hot hmm you
know what I mean so I'm like [ __ ] am I
even a hot person right see
[Laughter]
would you rather have someone who is
blind and they love you for your
personality or someone who's a shallow
ass deaf person
they love you for your looks I don't
want that [ __ ] because there's time or
would you rather have a shallow ass
like blind person that only likes you
for your voice oh the sound of your
voice yeah I need someone that likes me
for me because what if one day I'm
turning to a [ __ ] burn victim or
something you know oh so you'd rather be
with a blind person versus the deaf
person who's shallow shallow visual deaf
person yeah
I say all of the above how about that
dude I'm open to anything because you
could end up looking like Deadpool one
day yeah and you want someone to love
you for who you are that's very but they
might not like your smell because you'd
be smelling like charcoal and [ __ ] and
look how much personality Deadpool has
to have to still be likable yeah you
won't shut the [ __ ] up dude you need a
Brian Reynolds level Personality yeah
dude can you live up to Ryan Reynolds No
but I like I like the idea of somebody
liking me for different facets because
I'm sure in some days I'll need to make
up for a lack of one with the other true
it's like you know because if you're
only a good personality what if you're
like having a bad day yeah sometimes
that happens dude see unlovable make up
for something see Anthony I know it's
like usually see I'm a good vibe put my
[ __ ] uncle died today like oh wow no
like so yeah you can't love that person
for that day because they're gonna be a
bad he's a dick today there's definitely
had to have been times you were with
like an ex backing day or whatever and
she was pissing you off and then but you
looked at her like oh she's [ __ ] hot
you see Anthony
[Music]
[Music]